Paths and functions
of somatic afferents
and efferents of
the head and neck.
Video 3. Cranial nerves
9 through 12. This
is the final video
in the series and
will cover the remaining
cranial nerves.
As with video 2, I
recommend focusing
more on where the nerve
exits the endocranium
and skull and what
it innervates.
Cranial nerve 9. The
glossopharyngeal nerve.
nerve. This is the
main sensory nerve of
the pharynx, and is
responsible for both the
general and special
sense of taste for the
proximal one-third
of the tongue. The
glossopharyngeal nerve is
mostly a sensory nerve,
but it does contain a
single motor component
along with some autonomics.
This motor component
innervates the
stylopharyngeus muscle.
Glossopharyngeal leaves
the brain from the
medulla, where it exits
the endocranium and
the skull through the
jugular foramen. Just
inferior to the foramen,
the glossopharyngeal
nerve forms two
successive swellings, the
superior ganglion and
the inferior or petrous
ganglion. This is
where the afferent cell
bodies of the
glossopharyngeal nerve live.
Glossopharyngeal then
descends the neck,
running parallel to
the stylopharyngeus
muscle, sending branches
out to innervate
it as it goes.
Beyond stylopharyngeus,
the glossopharyngeal
nerve dives between
the superior
and middle pharyngeal
constrictor muscles,
sending out
multiple branches to
the pharyngeal plexus
as it descends.
These branches will
provide somatic sensory
information for
the entire pharynx.
Glossopharyngeal will
surface again on the
anterior side of the
pharyngeal constrictors,
where it terminates
in the posterior side
of the tongue,
innervating the proximal
one-third. The
glossopharyngeal nerve rarely
suffers damage and does
not really have any
common clinical
presentations associated
with it, so we'll move
on. The next nerve on
our tour is one that
we are all too familiar
with, cranial nerve
10, the vagus nerve.
Vagus comes from
the Latin word for
wandering or straying
and is a most apt
name for this cranial
nerve. The vagus
nerve is the only
cranial nerve to
extend beyond the head
and neck. The vagus
nerve serves as
the main carrier of
parasympathetic
innervation for the axial
region of the body,
sending branches as
far down as the first
two-thirds of the
transverse colon and
all of the kidneys.
There are even a
few branches that
sneak their way down
to the genitalia.
Vagus should be no
stranger to you at this
point, as we have
seen most of these
branches in previous
lectures and labs. For this
video, I'm only
going to focus on the
functions of vagus
within the head and neck.
The vagus nerve exits
the brain from the
medulla and travels
out the endocranium and
skull via the jugular
foramen. Similar to
the glossopharyngeal
nerve, the vagus
nerve will also form
two small swellings in
the jugular foramen, the
superior and inferior
ganglia of vagus. The
superior or jugular
ganglion is the
afferent component of
vagus, whereas the
inferior or nodos ganglion
handles the autonomic
motor functions.
In the head and neck,
there are just three
major branches of
the vagus nerve. The
pharyngeal branch,
the superior laryngeal
nerve, and the recurrent
laryngeal nerve.
The pharyngeal branch
is the first to
come off vagus and joins
with glossopharyngeal
to complete the
pharyngeal plexus.
Glossopharyngeal
provides the sensory
innervation, whereas the
pharyngeal branch provides
the motor to the three
pharyngeal constrictor
muscles. The
pharyngeal branch also
innervates all of the
muscles of the soft palate
except for tensor
velae palatini, which,
as we learned in video
2, receives innervation
from 5-3. The final
muscle innervated by
the pharyngeal branch
is the palatoglossus
muscle of the tongue.
The superior laryngeal
nerve is the next to
branch off vagus as it
descends the neck. This
nerve travels antero
-inferiorly to reach
the superior portion
of the larynx. As it
travels, it divides into
two smaller branches,
the internal and
external laryngeal nerves.
The internal laryngeal
nerve is the larger
of the two terminal
nerves. It is a sensory
nerve that provides
innervation for the
mucous membranes of the
laryngeal vestibule
and middle cavity,
including the vocal folds.
It will also send out
a branch to innervate
a small portion of the
tongue. The external
laryngeal nerve is
smaller than the internal
and is a strictly
motor nerve. It provides
motor innervation to
the inferior laryngeal
constrictor muscle
and sends another motor
branch to the cricothyroid
muscle of the larynx,
innervating it.
Note that cricothyroid
is the only
intrinsic laryngeal
muscle to be innervated
by the superior
laryngeal nerve. After
sending off the
superior laryngeal
nerve, vagus continues
to descend the neck
without sending any
further branches.
Once inside the thorax,
the vagus nerve sends
out one final branch
to the neck. This
branch loops back up
into the neck from the
thorax. It is the
recurrent laryngeal nerve.
Remember, the recurrent
laryngeal nerve
is asymmetrical
in where it loops
back. The left side
goes around the
arch of the aorta
near the ligamentum
arteriosum, whereas
the right side wraps
around the right
subclavian artery.
Both recurrent
laryngeal nerves travel
superiorly next to
the trachea in an area
called the
tracheoesophageal groove.
The recurrent
laryngeal nerves will
give off small
sensory branches along
the way, providing
sensory innervation
for the trachea
and esophagus.
The recurrent laryngeal
nerve ends when
it reaches the larynx.
Here, we change
the name to the inferior
laryngeal nerve.
The inferior laryngeal
nerve is the major
nerve supply for
the larynx. It has a
sensory component that
provides sensation
to the inferior
glottic cavity, and a
motor component that
handles all of the
other intrinsic
muscles of the larynx.
There are two branches
of the internal
laryngeal nerve. The
anterior branch supplies
most of our laryngeal
muscles, and the
posterior branch
supplies the remaining.
You will not be
asked to specifically
identify which branch
innervates which muscle.
Just remember that
the inferior laryngeal
nerve is the major
innovation for
these intrinsic
laryngeal muscles and
that cricothyroid is
the sole exception.
There are nine
pairs of laryngeal
muscles that move
the laryngeal
cartilages in
different ways.
Figure 9.39 from
Moore's offers a nice
summary of how these
muscles work. The
two most important
pieces of information
to learn at this
stage are that the
posterior cricoarytenoid
muscles are the
only muscles that
abduct the vocal folds
and that the cricothyroid
muscle is the
only intrinsic
laryngeal muscle not
innervated by the
inferior laryngeal nerve.
Lunachocorrelate
Damage to the recurrent
laryngeal nerve
happens during
surgical accidents
or as a consequence
of enlarged thyroid
tumors and aneurysms
of the aorta or
subclavian artery.
A lesion of the
recurrent laryngeal nerve
results in partial
or total paralysis
to most of the
intrinsic muscles of the
larynx. If the damage
is unilateral, the
patient will present
with what sounds
like a hoarse throat.
If the damage is
bilateral, then complete
mutinous results.
Bilateral paralysis
of the laryngeal
muscles leads to
difficulty breathing as
the vocal folds are
now not able to fully
abduct, resulting
in raspy breathing.
The next nerve that
we will look at is
cranial nerve 11, the
spinal accessory nerve.
Unlike the rest of the
cranial nerves, the
spinal accessory nerve
starts outside of
the skull within the
spine. Hence the name.
It begins as a
collection of rootlets
from the first five
to six cervical
segments of the spinal
cord. These rootlets
enter the skull
through the foramen
magnum. Once inside
the endocranium, the
fully formed nerve
will run together
with vagus as they both
exit the endocranium
and skull via the
jugular foramen.
From here, the spinal
accessory nerve
parts ways with vagus
and goes inferiorly,
paralleling the
internal carotid artery
before splitting
off to innervate the
sternocleidomastoid
and trapezius muscles.
These two muscles were
once a single, large
back muscle that can
still be seen in fish.
The evolution of
necks in land animals
required the head to
move separately from the
body, necessitating
the splitting of this
large back muscle into
two smaller muscles.
The shared innervation
from the spinal
accessory nerve is a
hallmark of that origin.
Clinical correlate.
Damage to the spinal
accessory nerve
is often the result
of an accident,
such as whiplash
from an automotive
collision or laceration
during surgery.
Lesions to the spinal
accessory nerve produce
weakness of the
trapezius, causing the
shoulders to droop
towards the affected side.
Spinal accessory lesions
can also occur during
childbirth if the
birthing process is
particularly difficult.
This results in
torticollis, or an abnormal
twisting of the neck,
caused by an entrapped
or shortening of the
sternocleidomastoid
muscle fibers. An acquired
form of torticollis,
known as spasmodic
torticollis, occurs
when a damaged cranial
nerve 11 becomes
hyperactive, causing the
sternocleidomastoid to
consistently contract.
In all of these
cases, the head will
tilt towards the
affected side
while the face
points away from it.
The final cranial
nerve in this series
is cranial nerve
12, the hypoglossal
nerve. This is the
chief motor supply
for most of the
muscles of the tongue.
Hypoglossal leaves
the brain near the
medulla and exits
the endocranium and
skull through the
hypoglossal canal.
After exiting the
skull, the hypoglossal
nerve initially
descends the neck before
changing direction
and moving anteriorly,
where it passes between
the internal carotid
artery and the
internal jugular vein.
As hypoglossal does
this, it picks up a
few hitchhikers from
the cervical plexus.
These nerve fibers
are conveyed to their
destination in the
superior root of ansa
cervicalis via the
hypoglossal nerve, despite
not actually being part
of the nerve itself.
Once hypoglossal
reaches the posterior
belly of digastric,
these hitchhiking nerve
fibers split off and
continue inferiorly
towards the
anticervicalis. At this
point, the hypoglossal
nerve changes
direction once more and
runs superiorly into
the base of the
tongue, where it fans
out to innervate all
of the tongue muscles,
with the exception
of palatoglossus.
Our tongue has
intrinsic muscles and
extrinsic muscles.
The intrinsic muscles
are hard to differentiate
in lab and are
deep within the
tongue. The comparisons
we care most about
are in regards to the
extrinsic muscles.
If the name ends in
glossus, it's an
extrinsic tongue muscle,
which means that
it attaches to the
tongue from somewhere
else on the body.
Genioglossus is the
large fan-shaped
muscle of the
tongue. It's the
most easily seen,
and it functions to
extend the tongue
from the mouth.
Hyoglossus does
the opposite,
retracting the tongue
and depressing it.
Styloglossus also
retracts the tongue,
but it will
elevate it as well.
So too will
palatoglossus.
Remember that
palatoglossus is the
only extrinsic
tongue muscle that
is not innervated
by hypoglossal.
Palatoglossus is
innervated by vagus.
The palate and tongue
are areas where
knowing which muscle
is innervated by
which nerve can get
a bit confusing.
To alleviate this,
Jack Stern from
Stony Brook University
came up with
a simple nesting
doll approach
that we now refer
to as Stern's Law.
The concept is
simple. If a muscle
has tensor in the
name, it is innervated
by cranial nerve
5-3, full stop.
If the muscle has
palate in the name, it
is innervated by
cranial nerve 10, unless
tensor is in the name
2. If the muscle has
glossus in the name,
it is innervated by
cranial nerve 12, unless
palate is present.
Each new rule
is superseded
by the rule before it.
Clinical correlate.
Damage to the hypoglossal
nerve presents
as weakness or paralysis
of tongue motions.
The geneoglossus
test is the
simplest way of
determining if
hypoglossal has
been damaged.
Geneoglossus is
a paired muscle,
and each side
receives innervation
from only one
hypoglossal nerve.
To test for a lesion
of the hypoglossal
nerve, patients are
asked to stick out
their tongue as
straight as they can,
activating their
genioglossus muscles.
If the nerve has
been damaged,
weakness or even
paralysis of
genioglossus will
cause the tongue to
deviate towards
the affected side.
We have just
learned about each
cranial nerve
in isolation.
However,
most head and neck
functions rely on
multiple cranial nerves
working in concert
with each other to
properly function.
let's briefly look at
two examples the gag
reflex this is a reflex
arc that keeps the
body from accidentally
ingesting an unexpected
food item it starts
when an unexpected
object comes into
contact with the back
of the pharynx this
triggers the afferent
limb of the gag reflex
which comes from the
glossopharyngeal nerve
in the pharyngeal
plexus glossopharyngeal
sends its afferent
signal back to a
specific nucleus in the
medulla, and this nucleus
communicates with an
adjacent nucleus that
sends a motor signal
via the vagus nerve,
triggering reverse
peristalsis, resulting
in the forceful expulsion
of the unexpected
object, or gagging.
Now, these are
the two big
nerves involved
with this reflex.
However, the reflex arc
may also incorporate
other nerves, such
as the mandibular
division of trigeminal
and hypoglossal,
opening the mouth and
lowering the tongue,
allowing for a
more efficient and
exaggerated expulsion
of the offending object.
Sensitivity and
contributions to the gag
reflex vary from person
to person, but it
does remain consistent
for any one person.
The gag reflex may
also just be missing.
Around 37% of
individuals do not
show an appreciable
gag reflex.
So that's one
example of multiple
nerves functioning
together.
Let's do one
more. This one
is a bit more
complicated.
Proper swallowing
or deglutition
requires the
precise coordination
of multiple
cranial nerves.
Deglutition is a
three-stage process.
The first stage takes
that food bolus and
pushes it to the back
of the mouth. This
is practically all
performed by our
tongue. The tongue
pushes and moves the food
item from the hard
to the soft palate,
bringing it to the
back of the throat.
This is a hypoglossal
dominant action.
The second stage is
the most complex.
Here we are taking
that food bolus and
dropping it into the
pharynx. To do this,
we need to get the
soft palate out of
the way. This is
accomplished via the
coordinated action
between the vagus nerve
and the mandibular
branch of trigeminal
via the nerve to
tensor velli palatini.
With the soft palate
out of the way, we
now have to widen
the pharynx. This is
done by activating
the longitudinal
muscles of the pharynx,
stylopharyngeus,
salpingopharyngeus,
and palatopharyngeus.
This requires activation
of our glossopharyngeal
and vagus nerves. As
these muscles lift
the larynx superiorly,
the epiglottis is
pushed closed over the
glottis, shutting off
our airway and preventing
us from choking.
The food can now
fall into the throat.
Our final stage
of deglutition is
the rhythmic
contraction of our
pharyngeal constrictors
as they push the
food bolus down
into the esophagus.
This peristaltic
action is done via
innervation from the
vagus nerve again.
So to summarize,
stage 1 is
hypoglossal dominant.
Stage 2, that's
the complicated
one. It involves
trigeminal,
glossopharyngeal,
and vagus.
Stage 3, that's
vagus dominant.
All these nerves must
function properly
for rhythmic
swallowing to occur.
The misfiring of
one or more of these
nerves produces
dysphagia, or
trouble swallowing,
as we can see here.
And with that,
we come to the
end of this video
lecture series.